all the time video games were built on
the backs of larger-than-life heroes
we've mowed our way through demons on
mars banish villains from a dozen
different high rules and toppled
dangerous ideologies in underwater
dystopias for most of the mediums
history games have granted us superhuman
powers and expansive Arsenal's of
weaponry but in 2012 four people began
work on a game that would go against
that current they had worked on triple-a
titles such as Bioshock 2 and BioShock
Infinite and recognized the potential
for a different kind of game so they
formed the fulbright company and began
work on their first release one that
took the environmental storytelling
aspects of the Bioshock series and
stripped away the rest weapons
superpowers over-the-top characters and
all in gone home players would explore a
mysterious house in the 1990s finding
clues to the whereabouts of their
missing family members
gaining insight through the things they
left behind five years later gone home
is lauded for the way it went against
the grain it spawned a wave of games in
its wake those that place us in the
shoes of ordinary people in relatable
situations and also prioritizing
narrative power over frantic action
what's more it told the coming-of-age
tale of gay characters diving headfirst
into topics that games as a medium have
often avoided since their inception now
four years after gone homes release we
traveled to Portland Oregon to discuss
the game's impact with those who made it
and those who have since joined the team
to relive how gone home sparked a new
genre challenge the definition of a
videogame and influenced their second
game Tacoma in 2017
but with a game like we make really what
you need is you know that kind of like
word of mouth thing for people to say I
played this game and now you have to
play it the biggest compliment you can
get and I think they were multiple of
these four gone home we're like reviews
that say if you haven't played the game
yet stop reading this review and just go
play it you know because like it means
that the people who played it valued
that experience so much that they don't
want to spoil it for someone else they
just want them to have it and then they
can talk about it and you know the the
fact that that can come through just
from us letting you get to know this
family was it was a really cool
experience what I thought initially um
and I apparently know nothing at all but
is uh but it would just be a weird
little niche thing and it would be one
of those like you know like okay a few
thousand people have played it they're
all they all like it for a specific
reason you know and we I didn't really
think that it would get popular outside
a narrow niche but I know having worked
on Bioshock 2 and then BioShock Infinite
in Boston that underlying set of design
values I think is really what we
continue to carry forward and what we do
because we're making stuff that is very
different Riley it doesn't have combat
it doesn't have emergent gameplay
results from what you do but in giving
you a game world to explore and I'm
giving you a role as a player to kind of
live in that world and be able to
interact deeply with what's there to you
know mine basically meaning and express
your intent within that experience
that's the core of what we really want
to put across with kind of
our relationship with the player and the
player's relationship with the game
world yeah this idea of letting players
pull story rather than pushing it on
them so giving them the tools to make
connections about the story by playing
the game and in their own head so a lot
of the game happens in the players head
right I love it as a player because it's
I mean I can't get that anywhere else
right like you can't you can't get that
feeling of authorship you can't get that
feeling of you know basically writing
the story in a way it's very
performative which also a lot of I feel
like a lot of games don't really hit
that for everyone a lot of games make
you feel more like a passenger than a
driver and I saw that and gone home
because I'm like yes and the sister
coming home from a trip of course I
would want to check the message machine
of course I would find a note on the
wall and like that says don't look
around and like well look around because
that's what that character would do one
of the closest things to it is something
like an escape room you know in the
physical world that's sort of a popular
thing is being made now or something
like certain immersive theater
productions like Sleep No More that is a
big influence on Tacoma where it's like
you're actually there and you are
driving your engagement with what you
find and you know having a satisfying
experience from actually investing
yourself in those things I think there's
something that that is just sort of the
people fund a minute to leave connect
with in that situation gone home wasn't
the first game to strip away skill based
gameplay in favor of an exploratory
approach in 2012 developer the Chinese
room released dear Esther a game that
led you through the remains of a
deserted island while you hear letters
read aloud from one man to his romantic
partner but whether through Fulbright's
ex bioshock pedigree or their
minimalistic approach to a relatable
plot gone home was the seminal release
that sparks similar games in the years
since releases such as fire watch
Virginia Kentucky route zero everybody's
gone to the rapture and what remains of
Edith Finch even triple-a developer
Naughty Dog made a similar section in
uncharted 4 when young Nathan Drake
explores a large empty house using
environmental clues to piece the story
together himself it's a brief respite
from the rest of an otherwise action to
have
game it's interesting putting out Tacoma
now after gone home has been out for
more than more than three years because
you know we're really lucky to be able
to say that I think that we can see how
gone home has been relevant to stuff
that's come out since then you know some
of that is with people that we're
friends with and that we know like you
know the folks at Campo Santo and made
fire watch it kind of feels like you
know gone home is part of this movement
or this sub-genre this kind of like part
of the design landscape that's being
explored right now which is which is
really cool and I kind of started making
games in like 2013 2012 2015 and at that
time got like games like on home and
come out recently and Kentucky route
zero Kart life and dysphoria are like
the four that I always remember playing
that year when I first started getting
into games and these were games that you
know my like new friends were showing me
that we're also making games they were
like this is like what's out right now
that's really cool that we think is like
exciting and doing new stuff so I played
gone home at that point had no idea who
Caesar Carla were just played it you
know and was like wow this is amazing it
totally had sort of the kind of
storytelling that I was excited about in
someone new to games so stories about
ordinary life and that was kind of what
I've been doing as a writer before in
poetry which is what I was more doing at
the time but you know just the other day
I played this free game that was on it
on itch itch do that someone had done a
demake have gone home by making an
interpretation of it as if you were
going through the Greenbriar families
like das computers so all the documents
in the game were like text file that
you're going through and just seeing
people have that kind of connection to
the game to the point that they want to
like make their own version of it or you
know do a let's play kind of commentary
where they're they're talking about
their interpretation of you know the
events of the game it means a lot when
you make something and then
it kind of remains relevant and people
are considering it along with other
things that they're doing you know years
later like the punk rock that permeates
GaN homes hallways fulbright was not
without its critics
in fact the phangan Holmes released in
2013
detractors were quick to ask if it could
actually be called a game there were no
challenges no combat scenarios no overt
puzzles and no way to fail
you could wander the house on Arbor Hill
for as long as you wanted and never
encounter any real challenge the term
walking simulator began as a derogatory
phrase for gone home and the games that
inspired and many felt as if they flew
in the face of what they had come to
know as the definition of a game however
much like the term punk-rock walking
simulator was later embraced by the
creators and fans of the genre it's
become an ironic badge of honor for
Studios that place narrative immersion
and emotional moments over a bombast and
spectacle
it definitely felt a little bit
surprising just because I felt like some
people were treating it as if the
ecosystem of games was like zero-sum but
it was like yes you have something that
is less competitive or what-have-you it
takes away from the world of games and
we're just kind of like it's I mean it's
just being added in there I don't
understand how like you think there's
like a finite like game pool of it like
everything draws bro I think they're
these kind of strata of that kind of
engagement with media which is to say
when you and I read the same book or
when you and I watch the same TV show or
movie the thing that we get to own is
our interpretation of it and that's
incredibly valuable and you know that's
basically what criticism and kind of
literature has been about as an
experience for for you know centuries I
think games are an interesting medium
because they're so they're still so
young and we're still finding so many
different ways of making games and we're
finding so many new ways to help players
engage with the system so you know
obviously one way is to have a fail
state and to challenge the players you
know motor skills for example that's one
one thing you can do but then there's
performance which draws on stuff like
D&D which is highly performative you
know you're creating this character and
playing out these situations and it's
pretty theatrical if you think about it
I'm curious if actually personally that
these kind of games would go in the
direction I'm interested in which is
actually making them more about
expression and taking
taking away things like story I mean not
saying like there should be no story but
in a way as soon as you are delivering a
linear narrative it's going to say the a
should come up for B and before C and it
usually means you have a role in it and
your role in some part is going to be
defined by the character you're supposed
to be inhabiting you just see new like
paradigms of game design happening all
the time especially now that making
games is pretty accessible like you can
get unity for free so you just have
people from different backgrounds who
have different ideas about what games
are making them and I think you know
with Fulbright it's really interesting
cuz Steven Carla comes from working on
Bioshock which is this like shooter game
but they saw something in that that
feels very different from what that is
but still draws on a lot of its
traditions and that's just something
that happens in art in general I think
it's just exciting to see you know game
designers being influenced by different
genres and finding new mechanics by
doing that and new ways of designing
games and thinking about what a game is
everything is just like evolving really
fast and people gone home was and still
is lauded for its approach to
storytelling but it's also notable for
the very story it tells it asks players
to potentially step out of their own
shoes to see highschool sibling
rivalries family life and growing up
through the eyes of someone who could
either be different from them or
painfully similar and rather than giving
you weapons acrobatic abilities or
puzzle solving skills to express
yourself fulbright decided to go down a
second path one charge with empathy and
understanding focused on the
coming-of-age story of a teenage girl
exploring her sexuality sometimes you
just have to lie to mom and dad like
when Lonnie asked me to see a band with
her and stay over at her friend's place
in the city after that's a lie to mom
and dad situation
but it was so worth it the girls on
stage were just so loud and real and
awesome and everybody was moving
together like one huge tide of sound
between two songs Lani leaned over and
said how do you like your first show I
was so happy I felt tears starting in my
eyes and then she up and hugged me I
think she could tell
you know let's say that there's parents
and a kid if the teenager fell in love
with someone they're not supposed to
that's a classic you know Romeo and
Juliet like that can be kind of
irreconcilable differences and lead to
real you know kind of human drama but if
we're setting it in the 90s it's not
really about montagues and capulets you
know if it was the queer story then
that's something that especially you
know 25 years ago could have caused real
conflict within a family unit but at
that point is when we kind of realized
well now this is what the game is about
and we now need to do the like real work
of research and interviews and trying to
understand enough about the perspective
that we can present it authentically you
know as a player I really like that
sense of of the game asking me to sort
of step out of my own shoes for a moment
and like think from the characters
perspective and do what I think they
would do so that kind of like
performative aspect of these kind of
games is really interesting to me and is
what I think really drew me and Devon
home you know the most other than the
ordinary life stuff was just a game that
gave me the tools sort of to role play
in this way and to perform the basic I
think important thing to us was that
that there were people who said you know
they felt like they knew these
characters like like real people like
people that they knew in their own lives
or just people saying like Sam is the
sister that I always wish I had or you
know something like that you know people
that are that are basically able to
engage with this kind of lenss into
these characters lives and picture them
as as kind of these fully realized
humans because at that point it just it
means that we were able to kind of
transport people into into the world of
of the green briars family and and that
you know all the things that were
important to them and seeing them as a
group of people that mattered to
them as they played because you know I
would much rather say oh this game let
me get to know this character like a
person and kind of like build some
empathy towards you know these these
people even though their imagined you
know they kind of represent experiences
that that you know people that you might
know or that you know you might meet
might have had or could have and I think
that anything that can give you that
expanded perspective of just like what
other people's life experience is like
it's a really valuable thing for us I
think it was walking a line of saying on
the one hand we don't want to say we
aren't going to explore this territory
because it's not what games are usually
about or because it's not what's most
obvious it familiar to us but also
taking it seriously and saying if we're
gonna do it we have to do it right and
work with people that can help us do a
better job and you know try to try to
put something out there that you know is
is worth engaging with you know for
anybody that that might encounter it
from a creative standpoint gone home is
in Fulbright's rearview mirror they
since turn their attention to Tacoma a
game set on a Space Station in the near
future and their second release as an
independent studio and from Fulbright's
point of view Tacoma has brought its own
set of challenges
the studio had proved the games could
flourish without combat or cinematics in
gone home they had gone against the
grain and sparked a new wave of stories
in the medium now it's the proverbial
tale of the sophomore effort how do you
move forward how do you carry the weight
of your breakout title how do you
develop your creative identity without
sacrificing what made you notable to
begin with
[Music]
your first thing out the reason it can
be kind of like a breakthrough hit is
because nobody expects anything right
and then when you're now you have an
identity and you're you're making
something new you're very lucky to be
able to say well there's gonna be a lot
of people who are excited about it just
cuz you made it but the other thing is
you go in with those expectations and
you really do have to kind of pay them
off yeah you don't have the luxury of
being able to say like well this game
isn't so great nobody's gonna notice
design-wise um we definitely tried to
build off of what we learned and making
gone home and improve where we could and
you know add sort of another layer
because it's it's one of those things
where you don't want to throw away all
the lessons that you've come by and so
you're like well I know all about making
this thing so maybe we should make
something kinda like it but you don't
want to repeat yourself fully and so you
want to have enough new stuff to keep it
interesting but you still want to have a
solid foundation and that is always
interesting challenge because like
where's that line Oh where's the point
at which it becomes interesting again
which is the point which it becomes a
retread you want players to pull you
know the story to find it and and we
want to give them the tools to do that
in as flexible a way as possible and I
think that that that sort of mentality
led to that ability distrubing so it's
just like the player wants to express
themselves in the system and find the
story at their own pace so we want to
enable that and I think that giving the
player the ability to scrub through the
scene at their own pace really helps
with that some people might want to just
watch it over and over that's not gonna
work for everyone but now we're saying
we can have these kinds of echoes of
characters in the space with you but not
just you stay on there and look at them
and you're like okay cool now I'm
watching an audio diary but making it
part of what you do interactively and
making it part of your role as the
player to interact with these recordings
or these you know scenes that you're
kind of inside of to see them from all
angles and kind of like build a
bigger understanding of what was going
on than any one person could if they
were actually in the room when it was
happening and so hopefully what that
means for someone looking at this
formally the player experience
perspective is that it's an expansion or
a further exploration of kind of what
that kind of you know environmental
storytelling first-person narrative kind
of game is it's looking at what you can
do in that experiential space from
another angle or with another kind of
layer of what the players role is built
on to it I feel like when you're working
on any game there's a certain amount of
pressure period and you kind of just
have to ignore it because otherwise
you're trying to please everyone in a
lot of ways and that's just kind of not
possible so you just end up being
stretched like every in every direction
and so like I don't know we kind of just
have to do what we think is a good idea
and what make sense to us because
there's no way to really internalize the
desires of everyone who plays games I
think what's important is that it's
resulted in us being able to make
something that we actually believe in
and that we feel like okay this is not
like something that we've ever played
before and this is worth making because
there's no other way that you're gonna
get this experience except for for
playing the thing that we're you know
working so hard on putting on screen
[Music]
every medium has its rebels though it
was unafraid to pursue originality when
so many others are eager to conform
we've gone home Fulbright did just that
they stripped away several tenets of the
Triple A games they themselves had
previously worked on they not only made
a game but asked what can games be with
Tacoma fulbright set out to prove that
they could refine walking simulators
that the genre still has weight that
they could continue to tell grounded
stories about people with their own
hopes and ease and flaws much like the
characters in Tacoma the members of
fulbright are constantly fighting back
against a massive tide of resistance and
like any bold creators they'll likely
continue to do so
[Music]
you